wenn die politik an dem ziel 50 oder ein
lauterbach vorschlag 25 festhielt geht
dieser look da noch mehrere monate wird
massive schäden verursachen dann
möglicherweise gar nicht viel nützen
ich bin der meinung das ist der falsche
weg ist und dass wir am anfang februar
über lockerungen reden müssen die
schulen müssen wieder aufmachen
kontrolliert natürlich das hat sogar
lauterbach befürwortet die kitas müssen
wieder aufmachen baden württemberg hat
ist zum glück vor einige länder waren da
immer weiteren verschärfung ich meine
schärfer als es jetzt ist geht es nicht
und wir können uns einfach nicht mehr
abverlangen als wir uns schon ab
verlangen
für mich ist da irgendwann das ende der
fahnenstange erreicht und diese 15
kilometer radien und die politik nur
noch einen freund treffen zu dürfen
zum glück hat macht baden württemberg
ist alles nicht mit das führt dazu dass
man die akzeptanz der menschen verlieren
in meinem umfeld ist jetzt schluss
schärfer geht nicht mehr
die leute sagen ich mach da nicht mehr
mit wenn er allein erziehenden mutter
verboten wird ihre eltern zu treffen
gehört es bei den leuten einfach auf
lauterbachs forderungen hin oder her wir
können nicht weiter wir können nicht
schärfer es reicht jetzt oder anfang
februar müssen wir kontrolliert wieder
aufmachen mit hygiene konzepten
selbstverständlich wir müssen auch leben